Yeah,
people often ask me how my parents
influenced me and I can't give a neutral
answer to that because I very much
influenced by saying by Hans,
I think that the biggest influence that
parents have on their children is at the
moment of conception.
I think that the people often attribute
far too much to parental upbringing.
There's a fair amount of data,
uh,
from my field that not widely known,
that suggests that the effect of,
of parents in shaping intellect and
personality might even be overrated when
you see this in children of immigrants,
even if their parents never acquired the
language and culture of the adopted
country.
As long as the kids were immersed in a
peer group,
they ended up as fully competent
citizens.
Something indeed that happened to my own
father,
the children of immigrants who are
culturally utterly inept to never
managed to,
uh,
speak the language.
And the case of my grandmother,
uh,
we're constantly at sea and figuring out
the culture.
And my father grew up highly successful.
So if you would ask the question of him,
how did your parents shape you?
He would have laughed.
He shaped himself a,
I don't want to deny credit to my
parents who brought me up in a rich and
stimulating a household,
but I think I'd be kind of inventing a
novelistic autobiography,
which is I think what most people do.
When asked,
how did your parents influence you?
That having been said,
uh,
it was a house with,
with books,
with discussion,
with arguments,
with people coming in,
uh,
and uh,
challenging us with interesting ideas so
I wouldn't have traded it for anything,
but the scientist in me says that warns
against my own tendency to tell a story
and how it explained who I am today.
It's natural to,
to credit who you are with your parents.
It seems like an act of,
of decency or gratitude.
And in fact,
I often have to apologize to my parents
saying,
I really do appreciate everything that
you did to me.
It's just that the scientific data lead
me to think that parents don't shape
children as much as most people think.
And their attitude is I should give them
credit for their attitude,
which is we would want you to say
anything but what you believe based on
the best scientific evidence that,
uh,
that you take seriously.
So don't try to fashion your answer to
have to flatter us,
uh,
that,
is a sign of the kind of people that
they are.
They are,
I think as interested in ideas and in
providing good reasons for your ideas.
Uh,
as I am.
I don't know whether I inherited that,
whether they fostered in me,
but,
uh,
they deserve a full credit for that even
if perhaps by the standards of their
friends,
I seem to be denying them credit.
And in talking about theories of the
shaping of personality,
I think the only way to make sense of a
nature and nurture is person.
Most obviously to point out that these
are not alternatives that I,
you couldn't have nurture.
That is the creation and transmission of
culture without a rich system of emotion
and learning to make sense of it.
To create the culture,
to acquire the culture.
If you're faced with it,
learning it as a child,
uh,
and in the other direction,
it would be a pretty useless kind of
innate human nature if it couldn't take
in information from the environment if
it couldn't figure out the kind of
physical and social world that had been
placed in a and soaked up information as
to how to,
uh,
to prosper in it,
in order to.
So you need both a,
how do they interact?
Well,
that happened.
You have to specify,
I think,
the innate motivational systems,
the innate learning mechanisms that make
learning and transmission of culture
possible.
So something is an eight.
What is it?
Eight is not concrete behaviors or
chunks of knowledge.
What is it?
Eight is an ability to analyze the world
and to learn in certain ways.
Language makes it a concrete.
We could not possibly be born with
English.
On the other hand,
just an ability to learn generically
isn't enough because you can take a baby
and you could take a,
a cat or a parrot,
give them the same environment.
The baby will learn to speak.
The cat won't.
Uh,
so something in neat must be there as
well.
In the case of language,
it would be a motive and an ability to
analyze the signals coming out of
someone else's mouth as being formed out
of units that have fixed meanings within
a community and competent tutorial rules
that allow new ideas to be expressed by
arranging these fixed signals in,
in different orders and combinations.
The brain mechanism that is equipped to
do that,
to find the words,
the nouns,
the verbs,
the phrases to analyze speech as having
that logic.
That's what's an eight,
a not just a generic ability to learn at
one extreme,
not knowledge of English.
At the other extreme.